die Engel Ben Kekse der Himmel rosaot es
ist die uns Verw hat und mit leckerin
belohnt es ist das Herz das hier lacht
es wird aus Liebe gemacht so ein
lieblicher Duft in der
[Musik]
Luft hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
Weihnachtsbäckerei heute gibt's wieder
eines unserer Lieblingsrezepte zu
Weihnachten und zwar mache ich heute
Zimtsterne aber das gehört wirklich
jetzt also wirklich mit Abstand zu den
Lieblingsplätzchen meines Mannes
mal mal jeden Plätzchenrezept Leute Ich
liebe jedes Plätzchenrezept mein Mann
liebt einfach alles was ich mache und
deswegen sind es alles unsere
Lieblingsrezepte ich gebe euch ja nur
meine Lieblingsrezept ich zeig euch
jetzt einfach mal die Zutaten und dann
starten wir auch direkt also wir
brauchen 500 g Mandeln die habe ich
jetzt bereits fein gemahlen 300 g
Puderzucker zweimal Eiweiß zwei
Esslöffel Zimt nee das waren zwei
Teelöffel sind zwei Teelöffel Zimt zwei
Esslöffel Mandelsirup oder auch
Mandellikör das sind die Zutaten für den
Teig und hier habe ich noch 125 g
putterzucker und ein Eiweiß das ist dann
für die Glasur zum Bestreichen der
Zimtsterne jetzt gebe ich zu erst einmal
die Mandel in meine Rührschüssel ihr
könnt es übrigens auch alles mit der
Hand machen ihr braucht da kein
Rührgerät dazu und mein Rezept
unterscheidet sich jetzt von anderen
Rezepten dadurch dass wir das Eiweiß
jetzt vorher nicht steif schlagen also
ich habe jetzt schon echt ganz viele
Rezepte ausprobiert früher waren meine
zimstäne zu hart aber wir wollen dass
sie schön weich sind und weich bleiben
und deswegen schlagen wir das Eiweiß
nicht steif sondern nehmen das so direkt
mit dazu ich gebe jetzt hier die 300 g
Puderzucker mit dazu wer es gern etwas
weniger süß mag nimmt einfach nur 200
ich lass jetzt auch mal ein bisschen weg
probieren wir jetzt heute mal so aus mit
etwas weniger Puderzucker und jetzt
verrühre ich einfach putudterzucker und
Mandel
miteinander ich gebe jetzt noch mein
Eiweiß mit
dazu und das
Zimtpulver und auch Mandelsirup oder
mandellör das wird jetzt einfach kurz
verknetet
erstmal kurz
verrührt und das ist übrigens völlig
normal dass die KitchenAid hier so ein
bisschen ruckelt das hilft nämlich also
wenn man z.B schwere Teige hat Nudelteig
heäfeteig dann wackelt es auch immer so
ein bisschen und zwar überhitzt dann der
Motor nicht bei anderen Maschinen bleibt
es ja dann so gerade stehen und dann
überanstrengt sich da der Motor so eine
umwucht
ja umwucht frälein umwucht und jetzt
gebe ich den Teig auf meine
Arbeitsfläche ich habe da jetzt eine
Silikonmatte dann klebt das jetzt hier
nicht alles auf meinem
Tisch jetzt einfach noch mal kurz mit
den Händen
durch ich könte ich könnte zu
Weihnachten Größen größere Backmatte
holen glaub nee Schatzi ich habe genug
aber du will mir unbedingt was schenken
ja also bei ist so wir schenken uns
eigentlich nichts zu Weihnachten
deswegen haben wir auch gesagt ich
könnte dir ach so wer nee also mir
schenkeen uns wirklich nichts zu
Weihnachten auch eigentlich nichts zum
Geburtstag weil weil du jedes mal mein
Geburtstag vergisst s erstens mal das
und zweitens mal brauche ich eigentlich
auch gar nichts mehr und irgendwie was
sinnloses kaufen nur damit was gekauft
hat wir verbringen lieber die Zeit
zusammen machen uns einen schönen Tag
ich schenke auch z.B meiner besten
Freundin immer irgendwie so ein
Gutschein oder sie mir auch was wir dann
zusammen erleben können und ja was
schenkt ihr euch eigentlich gegenseitig
zu Weihnachten oder zu Geburtstagen das
wird mich eigentlich schon mal
interessieren gibt's da auch jemanden
der nichts schenkt also mein Mann hat
mir auch zum ersten Hochzeitstag z.B
nichts geschenkt aber ich habe dir eine
Tochter geschenkt du hast mir eine
Tochter geschenkt ich habe die dir
geschenkt a aber das ist bei uns halt so
mir schenke uns halt NS so den Teig lege
ich jetzt ganz kurz zur Seite dann klebt
er nämlich auch nicht mehr so ich mache
hier ganz kurz sauber und dann werden
wir schon die Glasur zubereiten und dann
kannst gleich ans ausstechen gehen ich
werde jetzt hier noch schnell die Glasur
zubereiten und gebe jetzt einfach das
Eiweiß in meine
Rührschüssel lass es kurz steif schlagen
und dann kommt der Puderzucker mit
dazu jetzt kommt der pudterzucker miter
zu jetzt einfach nur so lange verrühren
bis sich alles vermischt
hat
und jetzt nehme ich mir meinen Teig und
nehme da jetzt erstmal nur die Hälfte
die andere
Hälfte ach komm ich ma gleich den ganzen
Teig so und habe den jetzt auf meiner
Silikonmatte mit etwas Puderzucker damit
es jetzt nicht
[Musik]
soklebt
so und jetzt nehme ich mir ein
ausrollstab und Roll da drüber und habe
hier übrigens auch meine Abstandshalter
also die habe ich jetzt auf 10 mm
eingestellt also werden die neckenon sen
die Zimtsterne gleich ein cm
[Musik]
hoch und jetzt nehme ich eine zweite
Silikonmatte und leg sie drüber und kann
das einmal umdrehen dann kann ich sicher
gehen dass da nichts dran kleben
bleibt und wenn ihr keine silikonmatten
habt könnt aber auch z.B Backpapier
nehmen aber auf den geht es einfacher
weil da eben NS
anklebt jetzt habe ich hier einen
zimtstnausstecher und zwar das Besondere
an diesem Ausstecher ist ich kann ihn so
seitlich öffnen ihr könnt natürlich auch
einen normalen Ausstecher nehmen aber
dann müsst ihr später von oben das
Plätzchen wieder runter drrücken weil es
ja schon ein klebriger Teig ist und mit
dem kann man es einfach öffnen und
herausnehmen ohne dass es kaputt geht
aber egal welchen Ausstecher ihr nehmt
ihr müsst den vorher in Puderzucker
eintauchen das Ding ist ja genial
normalerweise hät ich dasen müssen
dann ein bisschen ruckeln und jetzt kann
man das einfach rausnehmen und auch V
Backpapier
setz dass mein Mann sehr großzügig
zugeschnitten hat jetzt einfach vor
jedem Vorgang wieder
reinttauchen und
zustechen und wenn sie drauf kleben
bleiben ist auch nicht schlimm die
können wir dann gleich
[Musik]
runternehmen also in also in meiner
Familie gibt SAS nicht so Plätzchen
backen bei uns gab es das früher schon
immer ich meine meine Eltern und so
weiter die feieren zwar kein Weihnachten
aber Weihnachtsplätzchen gab es trotzdem
immer so im Dezember und da haben wir
uns halt richtig integriert
gell und dann könnt einfach so eine
minialette nehmen also iche min Palette
und könnt damit die Sternchen hier
wegnehmen also selbst wenn ihr ein
normalen Ausstecher habt ohne jetzt
diese auswerffunktion klappt es damit
eben
[Musik]
super während mein Mann jetzt noch die
restchtlichen Sterne aussticht kann ich
schon mal die Glasur drauf streichen und
zwar ma ich das einfach mit einem Pinsel
einmal drüber streichen klar das ist
jetzt ein bisschen aufwendig es gibt
auch extra zimtsternbleche dafür kann
man auch benutzen aber ich finde so ein
bisschen bestreichen und dekorieren das
gehört einfach mit dazu wenn man
Weihnachtsplätzchen backt weil im
Prinzip backt man die nur einmal im Jahr
und da braucht man sich nicht extra ein
Blech kaufen
[Musik]
dafür die zimtstellene werden jetzt im
Ofen bei 150° Umluft für etwa 10 bis 15
Minuten getrocknet ihr merkt wenn Sie
fertig sind wenn die Oberfläche
angetrocknet ist und dann heben wir Sie
kurz hoch und wenn sie unten auch
trocken sind dann sind die zimtstände
durch und da einfach in die unterste
Schiene damit die Oberfläche schön weiß
bleibt unsere zimtsteine sind jetzt
fertig sie haben bei mir etwa 12 Minuten
gebraucht ihr müsst da einfach
individuell schauen wie euer Ofen
funktioniert und wie lange sie bei euch
brauchen ich habe sie jetzt auch schon
abkühlen lassen und und habe sie hier
auf einer Platte serviert und mein Mann
darf jetzt mal
probieren riechen richtig lecker Zim
widerlich
ehrlich sie schmecken sehr
gut und damit sie weich bleiben dürf sie
nicht an der Luft offen stehen lassen
sondern gibt sie in so eine Blechdose
rein und da sind sie auch bestimmt zwei
Wochen haltbar wenn sie so lange halten
bei uns halten die eher nicht so lang ja
jetzt haben wir auch nur noch 40
Blechdosen da hab wir noch da hinten
Ecke sind auch noch welche ah ja da
stapeln sich schon die Plätzchen und da
unten und überall wir haben schon
überall Plätzchen ich kann sie schon gar
nicht me sehen so viel Plätzchen haben
wir schon und dieses Rezept gibt's
natürlich zum Nachlesen auf
sellies-blog.de ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr mir einen Kommentar da lasst ob
ihr zimsteine mögt wie ihr sie gerne
mögt und ob ihr das Rezept so auch schon
kanntet also ohne eiweißsteif schlagen
und ich wünsche euch auf jeden Fall noch
ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken wir gehen
jetzt noch eine Runde auf den
Weihnachtsmarkt oder ja wir gehen jetzt
no auf den Weihnachtsmarkt der Schnee
lässt noch ein bisschen auf sich warten
ich hoffe der kommt
noch und ja wir sehen uns dann beim
nächst mal wieder bis bald
[Musik]
tschüss
übrigens findet ihr alle Produkte die
ich heute benutzt habe auch bei mir im
Shop auf sellis-shop.de und ich wünsche
euch jetzt all noch eine richtig schöne
besinnliche Weihnachtszeit genießt die
Zeit mit euren Freunden mit eurer
Familie bis bald tschüss
tschüss